the most satisfying part of an
engineer's day is when they build
something knowing that they along with
millions of others would find it useful
with translator for Windows Phone we can
deliver translations when and where the
matter the most
I think the interactive aspect of the
augmented reality which is the piece
that I worked on when people see it's
more intuitive than maybe they expected
it to be there are a lot of things that
human brains do that are really hard for
computers to do what augmented reality
is really about is natural interaction
through vision we like to think that
it's very easy for people to just point
phone and see the translation magically
appear well if you're in a foreign
country and you are surrounded by text
in a language that you don't understand
you know this is this is especially true
if that text is written in a language
that you can't even reliably reproduce
it could be time-consuming when you are
on the road and have to pull up a
Chinese keyboard and just point at the
image and pan around so that you can
keep translating things as and when they
come into the view the voice mode is
really intended to be sort of a
conversational interface so we wanted
speech to speech translation people just
speak into the phone and the translated
speech comes out can you help me find
the bus station
[Music]
you know teacher okay the offline
translation mode is really intended for
people that are traveling without a data
connection we have compressed the engine
behind being translator to fit on a
phone in a language pack that you can
download you can translate on-the-go
avoiding data charges while roaming
Windows Phone was the perfect platform
to showcase what these technologies
could deliver to the user for instance
we were able to use the unique lifestyle
functionality of the platform to help
users learn new words in their favorite
language every day just pin the app to
your home screen and go our translation
system isn't perfect and sometimes you
get funny results this is always
something funny that you will encounter
along the way but the idea is to get
something so that you understand what's
going on this is a very very powerful
thing it's it's powerful in practice as
something that you can actually use
while you're traveling and it's powerful
in terms of what it does for you and
your everyday life hopefully you're
taking a step where you would feel a
little bit bolder to go to a place where
you won't have gone because you didn't
know the language that is very
satisfying
[Music]